. This is really important.
This next story, when there's a conclusion
of sorts to a major story.
It's really important to follow up on it.
And this week, what some previously dismissed
with this stupid term Russia gate has been
confirmed as very much not a hoax.
And, you know, it never gets as much attention
when the report comes out because you've got
to read it.
The corrections never get as much attention
as the headlines.
We know this is a reality in media.
But the Senate Select Committee has published
its report about Russian meddling in the 2016
election, and it confirmed a lot.
Now, I'm not expecting any apologies from
the lunatics who personally attacked me and
misstated what I claimed was the situation.
This is not about me, but I hope that we can
get into the record all of the things that
were not a hoax and were very much true.
And what the Senate report found is a direct
continuation of where Robert Mueller's investigation
arguably stopped short and didn't go far enough.
We got the fifth and last volume of the report
on Russia yesterday, and it shows without
a doubt that there has been no vindication
of Donald Trump or his campaign.
Now we know.
Well, let me back up.
We already knew from the Mueller report that
Donald Trump was not exonerated on obstruction.
We knew that from Mueller's report.
But this report from the Senate Select Committee
goes so much further.
Remember, as we dove into this, this is a
Senate controlled by Republicans right now.
This is not some left wing partizan perspective,
although certainly Democrat Mark Warner played
a big role in seeing this through.
Republican Richard Burr seems to have behaved
relatively morally in all of this.
But even without full cooperation from the
White House and whoever else, what the report
uncovers is extensive and it's just not getting
the attention it deserves.
Despite Paul Manafort s lies throughout the
investigation, they confirmed that Paul Manafort
and Konstantin Killam Nick, a Russian agent,
were in daily contact during the Trump campaign.
They were coordinating period.
They were communicating through encrypted
technology designed to automatically a race
their correspondence after it took place.
Wow.
That's interesting.
But the real bombshell here is that kill him,
Nick was likely a player in the Kremlin plan
to hack and leak the Hillary Clinton emails.
Yes, Oleg, Deripaska was connected to the
hacking.
But Vladimir Putin directed the way in which
the hack was going to be weaponized and carried
out.
Yeah, this is what the report found.
Putin knew and was directing at a high level.
This is according to a Senate committee controlled
by Republicans.
Yes, Roger Stone and Julian Assange from WikiLeaks
were intermediaries to all of this.
So you can come back and say, but David Trump
and Putin didn't personally set anything up.
I don't know who alleged that they did.
Certainly not on this program.
Roger Stone knew as early as August of 2016
that WikiLeaks had hacked John Podesta's e-mails.
And when the Access Hollywood grab him by
the, you know, what tape came out, they decided,
let's dump these now because the timing is
opportune.
The report exposes that Trump lied in his
written testimony to Robert Mueller about
not remembering conversations with Roger Stone.
Of course, since then, Trump has commuted
the sentence of Roger Stone in stones convictions.
So, again, expectations and avoiding hyperbole.
We.
By that I mean reasonable people like me said
from day one.
Guys, this is not going to lead to Donald
Trump's removal.
If you're expecting the Russia probe to uncover
video of Trump redhanded colluding with Putin
personally, that was never going to happen
because it didn't happen.
If you were expecting Trump to be removed
because of the investigation, that was never
going to happen.
But if you believe and I think as early as
April of 2017, I was saying that.
But if you believe that Trump basically has
a thing for Putin and other dictators and
he's just easy to manipulate, and the Trump
campaign was connected to Russia through WikiLeaks
in this hacking and a lot of other details,
the Senate report finds that it did happen.
And don't forget, Trump asked on live TV that
Russia hack Hillary's emails.
They did.
That wasn't trivial.
That actually you don't have to look too deep.
He said it publicly.
And it's what happened.
And Manafort was in touch with Killam, Nick.
And it it all happened.
OK, so then the question is, what now?
Nothing.
I mean, they're not going to be held accountable.
Just put it out of your mind.
The accountability would be voting Trump out
in November, relegating Trump to being a one
term president who leaves after one term with
a disastrous record and embarrassed.
Of course he will, because of his narcissism,
find some way out of it.
But who cares?
It's for the good of the country.
That's what we have left.
Either Trump has made a one term president
or Trump is rewarded with another four years.
That's what it is.
Sunday is the 15th anniversary of the David
Pakman show.
We'll be doing a one day membership special.
I hope you'll partake.
A sign onto our newsletter at David Pakman
dot com.
And Sunday afternoon you'll get an email telling
you how to take advantage of this insane,
possibly illegal, certainly immoral membership
discount.
Just get grabbed that newsletter subscription
for free at David Pakman dot com.
The David Pakman
Show
David Pakman dot com.